[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Freitagabend viele spannende sportliche
Wettkämpfe kriegen sie gleich von
Norbert Lehmann schönen guten Abend von
mir und dieses Foto von Donald Trump
geht um die Welt
Aufnahme für die Geschichtsbücher als
erster exos-präsident muss Donald Trump
für ein Polizeifoto posieren er nutzt es
für den Wahlkampf
wer steckt hinter dem
nordstream-anschlag nach Recherchen von
ZDF und Spiegel führen die Spuren die
Ermittler in Ukraine
und gute Medaillenchancen zehn Kämpfer
Leo Neugebauer startet bei der
Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaft furios
und liegt nach drei Wettkämpfen
souveränenführung
[Applaus]
noch nie musste ein ehemaliger
US-Präsident in einem Gefängnis
erscheinen bis jetzt Donald Trump
stellte sich wegen des Vorwurfs der
Wahlbeeinflussung im Bundesstaat Georgia
den Behörden das Polizeifoto nutzt Trump
dabei gleich für den Wahlkampf er will
als Kandidat der Republikaner bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl im November
geschichtsträchtiger kurztermin für
einen Ex-Präsidenten mit der privaten
Boeing nach Atlanta für 20 Minuten Knast
hinter den Mauern des fulten County Jay
werden Donald Trumps Fingerabdrücke
genommen und er wird abgelichtet
heftling Nummer 1 1 3 5 8 0 9 die
trump-kampagne nutzt das Foto als Symbol
eine angeblichen Hexenjagd verkauft
Tassen T-Shirts Caps auf der Twitter
nachfolgeplattform x meldet sich Trump
erstmals seit zweieinhalb Jahren mit
Schlachtrufen wahleinmischung niemals
aufgeben
er will nicht schwach Aussehen darum
geht es ihm das gefängnisfoto und Umlauf
zu bringen damit Spenden zusammen dazu
zu stehen das ist alles Teil seines
üblichen Drehbuchs aber das bedeutet
nicht dass er das genießt
vor dem Gefängnis Anhänger und Gegner
Trumps jeweils mit ihrer eigenen Sicht
auf die Dinge
es ist eine Farce sie wollen ihn fesseln
und ihm das Geld aus der Tasche ziehen
und seine Familie und ihn blamieren
das geht hoffentlich in die Geschichte
ein und wird eines der letzten Male dass
wir von dieser Person hören müssen die
Staatsanwaltschaft ist sich sicher Trump
wollte seine Niederlage in Georgia
drehen unter anderem durch ein Telefonat
mit dem obersten Wahlleiter des
Bundestags
[Musik]
es ist das zentrale Beweisstück in
dieser vierten Anklage Donald Trump
stellt sich weiter unschuldig und
spricht von einem traurigen Tag für
Amerika
200.000 Dollar Kaution musste er
hinterlegen damit er als freier Mann
abreisen kann aber für das Verfahren
wird man Donald Trump in Atlanta wo noch
öfter sehen
David sauer schadet das ganze jetzt
schon oder nutzt es ihm sogar
ja also kurzfristig wird es ihm
wahrscheinlich nutzen weil es ja zu 100
Prozent einzahlt auf seinen narrativ
dieser angeblichen Hexenjagd alle gegen
einen und Donald Trump als Opfer vor
allem dieses Foto steht für ihn dafür
und es wird dann nutzen um Wahlkampf zu
machen und um Spenden zu sammeln
Experten glauben aber dass es ihm
mittelfristig eher doch Schaden wird
warum zum einen weil es in diesem Fall
wahrscheinlich ein öffentliches
Verfahren wird es wird wohl Kameras im
gerichtssa geben so dass ganz Amerika
sich ein Bild davon machen kann wie in
diesem Fall die Beweise stehen und zum
anderen gibt es hier im Verfahren eine
ganze Reihe von mit Angeklagten und es
ist durchaus möglich dass da einer oder
eine sich entschließt gegen Donald Trump
auszusagen und somit sich selber dann
rein wäscht und außerdem ist es in
diesem Fall ein bundesstaatsverfahren
und kein bundesverfahren das bedeutet
sollte Donald Trump in diesem Fall
verurteilt werden und sollte er noch mal
zum vereinigten Präsidenten der
Vereinigten Staaten gewählt werden dann
kann er sich nicht selber begnadigen
danke schön für diese Einordnung David
sauer
nach dem mutmaßlichen Tod des russischen
Söldner Führers bregorien sammelt sich
seine wagnertruppe angeblich in Belarus
Diktator Lukaschenko kündigte an in
wenigen Tagen sein alle 10.000 Mann im
Land
US-Geheimdienste gehen nicht davon aus
dass eine Rakete für den tödlichen
Flugzeugabsturz verantwortlich war
derweil weist der Kreml eine russische
Verwicklung in den Absturz der Maschine
zurück und bezeichnet gegenteilige
Verdächtigungen als Lüge
putinsprecher pierskov sagte die
Untersuchungen dauerten noch an
wer steckt hinter den Anschlägen auf die
Nord Stream Pipelines auch rund ein Jahr
danach ist diese Frage noch immer nicht
beantwortet aber immer mehr Hinweise
zeigen Richtung Ukraine
am 26 September 2022 waren drei der
insgesamt vier Stränge der Gaspipelines
nordium 1 und 2 auf dem Grund der Ostsee
durch Explosion zerstört worden ein Team
von Journalistinnen und Journalisten von
ZDF frontal und Spiegel hat sich jetzt
auf Spurensuche begeben mehr von David
Gebert
ein Segelboot im Fokus der Weltpolitik
nach Recherchen von ZDF frontal und
Spiegel zweifeln deutsche Ermittler kaum
noch das mit Hilfe der Andromeda die
Nord Stream Pipelines gesprengt worden
politisch hoch brisant vor und nach der
Sabotage soll die Crew laut fahren dann
in der Ukraine gewesen sein ich begrüße
dass das jetzt die Informationen an die
Öffentlichkeit gegeben werden all das
was daraus kam ändert nichts an den
Umstand das Putin ein Angriffskrieg in
die Ukraine führt und wir die Ukraine
unterstützen wir ja Verteidigung
gleichwohl müssen solche Anschläge
aufgeklärt werden das kann nicht sein
dass man das sortiert auf einem dieser
Ergebnis gefällt oder nicht die
Aufklärung der Nord Stream Sabotage ein
Fall für die Bundesanwaltschaft im
Januar lässt sie die Verdächtige
Andromeda durchsuchen auf dem Tisch
finden die fahrende Reste von
Sprengstoff wie auch bei den geborsten
Röhren am Meeresgrund es ist derselbe
wer war an Bord unser Reporter-Team
macht in Moldau Stefan makuh ausfindig
die Passnummer die wir ihm vorlegen
gehört zu seinem im Oktober abgelaufenen
rumänischen Pass und soll für die
andromeda-anmietung genutzt worden sein
ich war im September 2022 in Moldawien
und habe gearbeitet von der nordstream
Explosion habe ich aus der Presse
erfahren offenbar Datenklau Markus
Passnummer aber das Foto eines viel
jüngeren Mannes auf dem Ausweis der für
die Anmietung der Andromeda genutzt
wurde dieses Foto führt zu valerica
offenbar Soldat wohl bei der 93
mechanisierten Brigade der ukrainischen
Armee es gibt bisher keine Belege dass
der ukrainische Staat an den Anschlägen
beteiligt war und eine betreuerung
haben wir nichts zu tun die
Bundesregierung unter Druck endlich
Ermittlungsergebnisse zu präsentieren
Innenministerin Fräser erklärt heute ich
erhoffe mir dass der Generalbundesanwalt
genügend Anhaltspunkte findet um die
Täter anzuklagen die Spuren verdichten
sich fahrende haben technische Daten
unter anderem IP-Adressen ausgewertet
nach ihrer Mission soll sich die
Andromeda Crew laut Ermittlern abgesetzt
haben und zwar in die Ukraine
viele drängende Fragen bleiben mehr zu
dem Thema haben wir in unserer ZDF heute
App dort gibt es auch die Dokumentation
der Fall Nord Stream Spurensuche auf der
Ostsee in voller Länge
Hass und Hetze im Internet sind ja eine
riesiges Problem aber auch
personalisierte Werbung die Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer gezielt anspricht seit heute
gelten in der EU deshalb schärfere
Vorschriften sie betreffen die ganz
großen Online-Dienste die Plattform
müssen jetzt unter anderem illegale
Inhalte unverzüglich löschen und ihre
eigenen Algorithmen transparenter machen
sensible Daten wie politische
Einstellung oder Religion dürfen sie
nicht für gezielte Werbung nutzen bei
Verstoß drohen hohe Strafen von bis zu
sechs Prozent des Umsatzes bei Amazon
zum Beispiel wären das 28 Milliarden
Euro
es herrscht viel Unsicherheit in der
deutschen Wirtschaft nach der jüngsten
Umfrage des ifo-Instituts haben sich die
Geschäftserwartungen in den Chefetagen
der Unternehmen im vierten Monat
hintereinander verschlechtert zahlen die
auch in den Städten sorgen auslösen bei
den Einzelhändlern etwa welche Folgen
das auch für die Verbraucher hat zeigt
an seinem Stern am Beispiel Trier
es werden immer mehr die aufhören die
aufgeben kleine und große Händler machen
ihre Geschäfte zu selbst hier in der
beliebten und beliebten Innenstadt von
Trier
die Situation für den Einzelhandel ist
sehr schwierig im Moment die Kosten die
steigen das heißt Personalkosten steigen
die Energiekosten steigen die Mieten
sind enorm hoch mehr kosten und weniger
Einnahmen weil auch die Verbraucher
jeden Tag die Inflation zu spüren
bekommen die Folge immer mehr Leerstand
es ist nicht gut weil so kann man auch
die Sachen nicht mehr sich ja live
anschauen im Internet bestellen ist
natürlich praktisch aber mich persönlich
nerven auch die Retouren alles ist
teurer geworden da muss man schon gucken
der Handelsverband Deutschland rechnet
damit dass in diesem Jahr etwa 9000
Geschäfte bundesweit für immer dicht
machen müssen wir sehen schon eine
wirklich dramatische Situation von
Geschäftsaufgaben klar nach zwei Jahren
Corona ist bei vielen Unternehmen das
Eigenkapital einfach nicht mehr da die
konsumentensituation ist nicht wirklich
optimal und gerade kleinere Städte haben
den größere Nachteil davon dass ihm auch
Geschäfte aufgegeben werden die Inhaber
keine Zukunft mehr sehen keine guten
Aussichten im Handel und längst nicht
nur da die stimmungs- und Auftragslage
wird insgesamt weiter schlechter
zum vierten Mal in Folge gefallen und
zwar auf breiter Freund es gibt
eigentlich kaum eine Branche die als
Lichtblick bezeichnet werden kann also
die Stimmung ist sehr breit
zurückgegangen Händler fordern
staatliche Investitionen zum Beispiel
mehr Grünflächen mehr Plätze zum
Verweilen in den Innenstädten in denen
die Menschen ganz schön zu kämpfen haben
mit den Folgen der Inflation
ein toter mehrere Verletzte verwüstete
Campingplätze reihenweise umgestürzte
Bäume über den Süden Deutschlands ist in
der Nacht eine Gewitterfront mit
Starkregen und sturmeln gezogen Polizei
und Feuerwehr waren im Dauereinsatz
Volker Duce
schlimm erwischt hat es Lindau am
Bodensee vieles hier auf dem
Campingplatz hat nur noch Schrott
während als das Gewitter gestern Abend
über die Camper hereinbricht erreicht
der Wind Orkanstärke 144 Kilometer pro
Stunde mindestens sechs Menschen werden
verletzt der Wohnwagen hat Gebet wir
sind mit den Kindern ins Auto geflüchtet
es sind Bäume rausgerissen das sind
komplette Wohnwagen Autos getroffen es
hat alles zerfetzt das ist wirklich übel
die Einsatzkräfte sperren den Platz rund
900 Camper machen sich mit kleinem
Gepäck und mit Bussen auf den Weg ins
Kongresszentrum das zum provisorischen
Nachtquartier wird
in Steinheim an der Mur in
Baden-Württemberg wird der Dauerregen
zur Gefahr für Autofahrer und bei deiner
Bushaltestelle kracht ein Baum auf ein
Auto die drei Insassen darunter ein Kind
bleiben unverletzt viele Bahnreisenden
in Bayern und Baden-Württemberg müssen
eine Pause einlegen viele Bäume und Äste
auf den Oberleitung kein Strom mehr
keine Weiterfahrt im Regionalverkehr
verspäten sich noch am Morgen die Züge
36 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter in
Freiburg in Baden-Württemberg werden
Radler und Autofahrer vom heftigen Regen
überrascht viele Geschäfte in der
Altstadt unter Wasser die weggeschwemmte
Außenbestuhlung holen sich die
Mitarbeiter noch während des Sturms
zurück
im Südwesten und Süden gibt es noch
keine Entwarnung auch heute Abend wird
mit Regen gerechnet und der ist
langanhaltend und kräftig
die Waldbrände halten Griechenland
weiter im Griff inzwischen wurden zwei
weitere Leichen in den brandgebieten
gefunden am heftigsten wüten die Flammen
in der nördlichen Air France Region die
Behörden sagen die meisten Feuer seien
von Brandstiftern gelegt worden
bereits zu Wochenbeginn starben 18
Migranten die vom Feuer eingeschlossen
worden waren
masern sind hochansteckend und können zu
schweren Komplikationen führen in
Deutschland gilt daher seit mehr als
drei Jahren eine Masern Impfpflicht
unter anderem für Schul- und Kita Kinder
und alle die dort arbeiten in Halle an
der Saale gab es jetzt aber mehrere
Masernfälle mehr dazu von Andreas Weise
Halle an der Saale ein Masernausbruch
Ende Juli sorgt für Aufregung waren die
Zahlen während der corona-zeit gesunken
steigen Sie jetzt wieder 15 Erkrankte in
Halle so viele wie bundesweit im ganzen
letzten Jahr elf davon müssen stationär
behandelt werden die hatten also
entweder eine Lungenentzündung noch als
Komplikation oder eine
Mittelohrentzündung bzw alle hatten sehr
hohes und anhaltendes Fieber was durch
die gängigen Medikamente und Hausmittel
nicht zu backen flossen war und der
Allgemeinzustand der betreffen hatte
sich von Krankheitsbeginn dann an
zunehmend verschlechtert das ist durch
all die Debatten um die Corona
Impfpflicht mehr Ablehnung der Masern
Prävention gibt kann Kinderarzt Detlef
Wendt nicht erkennen es sei eher so dass
vielen nicht mehr bewusst ist wie
ansteckend gefährlich masern sind
masern sind unglaublich infektiös also
wenn einer im Wartezimmer sitzt und
hustet ein bisschen der verteilter die
Viren und das geht quer durch die Luft
und Sie müssen nicht direkt daneben
sitzen im angesteckt zu werden
langfristige Schädigung des Gehirns die
bis zum Tod führen können treten extrem
selten auf trotzdem ist es Ziel die
Masern weltweit auszurotten in
Deutschland geltende Impfpflicht soll
dazu beitragen Schüler allerdings dürfen
trotz fehlendem Impfschutz zum
Unterricht Schüler dürfen
Grundschulunterricht nicht
ausgeschlossen werden weil die
Schulpflicht über der Impfpflicht steht
nach dem Ausbruch setzt Halle jetzt auf
Aufklärung und Beratung in den kommenden
zwei Wochen kann hier der Impfstatus auf
Sonderterminen abgefragt und
aufgefrischt werden
viele werden es auf der Fahrt in den
Urlaub bemerkt haben Wohnmobile und
Wohnwagen sind auch nach der Pandemie
beliebt entsprechend optimistisch ist
die Branche zum Beginn des Caravan
Salons in Düsseldorf
besonders Wohnmobile bleiben gefragt in
diesem Jahr wurden bereits über 47.000
neu zugelassen im Vergleich zum gleichen
Zeitraum in den letzten Jahren sind das
zwar weniger als wären Corona in 2020
und 21 aber fast 16 Prozent mehr als vor
der Pandemie hat sich die neuesten
Trends rund ums mobile Reisen angeschaut
Campen ja aber wie das ist die Frage und
geklärt wird sie hier in der starterwelt
beim Caravan Salon in Düsseldorf was
passt zu welchem Campingurlaub soll es
eher der Camper Wellen für Städtereisen
sein oder darfst doch teurer und
komfortabler sein mit extra Duschkabine
hier gibt es Rad für den ganz
persönlichen Modell Kompromiss oft ist
es so dass die Leute die Vorstellung
eines Wohnkomforts eines acht Meter
Fahrzeugs haben aber gerne von den
Abmessungen maximal sechs Meter möchten
und wenn man nachher eine Fragen stellt
was haben Sie denn genau damit vor dann
kristallisiert sich heraus dass man auch
mit etwas weniger zu recht kommt ganz
minimalistisch aber bezahlt ist Daria
Radlers VW Bus alles selbst gebaut das
habe ich selbst gebaut genau Kosten
insgesamt 6000 € und ein halbes Jahr
Ausbauzeit also gemütlich ist es perfekt
gerade in Italien ich war viel in
Italien die kleinen Straßen die engen
Gassen ich bin durchgekommen wo andere
nicht mehr lang fahren konnten es gibt
für jedes Ziel und jedes Gelände
eine Lösung auch für jeden Anspruch
zumindest wenn man sich am oberen Ende
der Preisskala orientieren kann die
liegt bei rund anderthalb Millionen Euro
größer und teurer
geht immer vorausgesetzt man hat einen
LKW-Führerschein aber auch unter 3,5
Tonnen Gesamtgewicht gibt es genug was
Reisemobilisten Herzen höher schlagen
lässt und dann gibt es auch sie Elektro
Camper Vans mit rund 400 Kilometern
Reichweite und ausgeklügeltem
Innenausbau auf aller engstem Raum
preislich sind die elektrischen
Varianten gar nicht so weit entfernt von
ihren verbrennerkollegen zumindest bei
den Vans aber sie sind kleiner und
schwerer immerhin die Elektromobilität
ist bei den Reisemobilen angekommen
der spanische fußballverbandchef Luis
robiliales weigert sich zurückzutreten
nachdem er eine Nationalspielerin bei
der WM Siegerehrung ungefragt auf den
Mund geküsst hat viele sind hört auch
aus dem Fußball und der Politik das
rubiales im Amt bleiben will über die
außerordentliche Generalversammlung des
spanischen Verbandes berichtet Thomas
Walde
Spaniens fußballverbandschef zeigte sich
heute trotzig Noro ich trete nicht
zurück ich trete nicht zurück ich trete
nicht zurück
ich trete nicht zurück ich trete nicht
[Applaus]
zurückianis versuchte die Kritik an ihm
abzutun und sich als Opfer darzustellen
ein kleiner einvernehmlicher Kuss soll
mich hier rausbringen
nachdem wir im Finale hat der rubiales
die Spielerin Jennifer ermussow auf den
Mund geküsst in sozialen Medien sagte er
muss so das habe ihr nicht gefallen
Spaniens Ministerpräsident Petrus
Sanchez empfingen die Weltmeisterinnen
nach ihrer Rückkehr freundlich und den
Verband Chef frostig Sanchez kritisierte
rubiales Ministerin sprachen von
sexueller Gewalt das rubiales gleichwohl
im Amt bleibt ruft heute Empörung hervor
die Spielerin Alexia putella lassen das
inakzeptabel der Spieler bausa Iglesias
verkündet aus Protest seinen Rückzug aus
der Nationalmannschaft
wir werden alles aktivieren was in
unserer Hand ist damit dieser Herr den
man schwerlich als würdigen Vertreter
des spanischen Fußballs bezeichnen kann
nicht weiter an der Spitze des Fußballs
in Spanien steht
die Regierung will nun das Sportgericht
anrufen und das fortschrittliche Spanien
das zuletzt die Rechte von Frauen
gestärkt hatte hat eine neue Diskussion
über sexuelle Gewalt die über den Sport
hinausgeht
und jetzt kommen wir zur WM in der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik Norbert oder
besser gesagt zu den Meer Festspielen ja
unglaublich was da abgeht in Valencia
vorgestern zweimal Gold für die
16-jährige deutsche gestern abend wieder
zweimal Gold da ja fahr vor volle mega
gewinnt alle WM Einzeltitel das hat noch
keine deutsche Gymnastik geschafft
von
allen die größten Schwierigkeiten und
das ganze mit einer Leichtigkeit die die
Fans der Gymnastik WM in Valencia
begeistert die Publikum ist richtig laut
und voll viele Menschen sind angekommen
das ist das finde ich am Band gewinnt
die 16-jährige auch die zweite
Goldmedaille des Abends und morgen steht
der wichtigste Wettkampf für die
Ausnahmeathletin an der meerkampf und
natürlich ist die fünfte Goldmedaille
das Ziel
[Applaus]
so Verena Auftakt der deutschen
Basketball dabei der WM in Japan 81 zu
63 gegen die Gastgeber das Turnier Ziel
ist ehrgeizig nach 21 Jahren wieder eine
mit bmmedaille kämpfen
ausgelassenen Begeisterung auch unter
den japanischen Besuchern die deutsche
Mannschaft dominiert ohne zu glänzen
Moritz Wagner von Orlando Magic erzielt
25 Punkte er ist einer von vier
Deutschen aus der NBA der
nordamerikanischen Basketball-Liga
nach gutem beginnen lässt Deutschland
aber nach und Sorgen macht Frank Wagner
der mit dem Fuß umknickt wie schwer die
Verletzung ist ist noch unklar
schließlich ein 81 zu 63 der erwartete
Auftakt sieht
die Deutschen hockeyfrauen haben den
EM-Finale Einzug verpasst durch das 0:1
gestern Abend gegen Belgien morgen geht
zum Bronze die Männer spielen gleich im
Halbfinale gegen England live zu sehen
ab 21:15 Uhr bei
sportstudio.de zur Leichtathletik WM in
Budapest da könnte es morgen endlich die
erste deutsche Medaille geben denn heute
hat ein Zehnkämpfer einen sowas von
brillantenstart Leo Neugebauer
Freude beim deutschen Shooting Star der
zehn Kämpfer Leo Neugebauer er führender
nach drei Disziplinen in Budapest auch
danke dieses Sprungs über 8m persönliche
Bestleistungen Weitsprung der nationale
Konkurrenz Niklas Paul mit Hüftproblemen
der Europameister 19 nach drei Disziplin
seine Stärke aber ist der zweite Tag Leo
Neugebauer zeigt schon heute Muskeln 17
Meter und vier mit der Kugel Weltklasse
macht viel Spaß ein geiles Stadion ich
liebe das Wetter ich bin ja ich
trainiere einen Textes wo es immer warm
ist deswegen genieße ich die Hitze hier
sehr der kanadische Olympiasieger Damien
Warner mit 96 Punkten Rückstand zweiter
von Landsmann leparsch ganz vorne aber
er Leo Neugebauer die deutschen Fans
voller Hoffnung dass es Samstag klappt
mit einem Medaille für die deutschen
Zehnkämpfer
der Zehnkampf geht gleich live weiter
bei uns im ZDF 1925
Morgen erneut schwere Gewitter
mehr Berlin
trifft das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der erste kalte
Vorstoß bis in die Mittelmeerregion
steht an und diese Kaltluft produziert
hier direkt ein tief und dieses Tief hat
es in sich 200 bis 300 Liter auf den
Quadratmeter sind in den Alpen punktuell
möglich und das wird zu murenabgang und
zu Überflutung führen behalten Sie das
im Auge wenn sie dort unterwegs sind in
Deutschland geht es aber auch zur Sache
im Norden sind einige Gewitter unterwegs
die ziehen raus im Süden sind ebenfalls
Gewitter und diesen teilweise Unwetter
artig mit Starkregen Hagel und Sturmböen
Temperaturen 20 Grad im Osten und 11
Grad im Westen sie sehen hier die
Temperaturen es ist schon mal deutlich
kühler morgen dann im Norden einige
Schauer und Gewitter in der Mitte
teilweise trocken zum Nachmittag dann im
Süden unwetterartige Entwicklung wieder
mit starken Hagel und Sturm und dazu
Temperaturen von 27 jetzt gerade im
Osten und 20 Grad ganz im Westen 19 in
Schleswig-Holstein ja und dieses Wetter
diese extreme Wetter an den Alpen setzt
sich weiter fort hier große ringmengen
zu erwarten 15 bis 22 Grad und in den
nächsten Tagen allmählich trockener und
kühler ein schöner Abend